so wie ich das einfach leute geführt und
dann kannst du welches interesse
ok hallo leute ist egal
ich begrüße euch zu einer premiere denn
es war ihr wunsch dass ich nicht mal ein
bisschen mehr vor der kamera zeigt damit
meine küche umgestellt das ist das erste
video nehme ich nicht vor der kamera
zeige ich habe euch auch mit ganz
besondere torte mitgebracht nämlich
diese leckere yogurette torte und ich
bin ganz gespannt was ihr dazu sagt wir
benötigen erdbeeren ist es egal ob e
tiefkühl erdbeeren oder frische nimmt
ich zeig euch jetzt mal die tiefkühl
variante weil die das ganze jahr über
gemacht werden kann
außerdem etwas leitungswasser ein wenig
engagiere und falls sie etwa nicht süß
genug sind noch etwas zucker für die
erdbeer frucht anlage nehmen wir uns
einfach die erdbeeren geben unseren topf
und dann kochen wir das ganze zwei
minuten lang auf
[Musik]
bevor das wasser erhitzt dem wir noch
schnell unsere adina und den zucker mit
hinzu und sind so dass für das gut
verrühren damit sich alles gut verbindet
nehmt ihr dann am besten einen
schneebesen so die masse kocht jetzt
jetzt müssen wir das zwei minuten lang
köcheln lassen damit die agah teenagern
ihren kann und wer mag kann die hat
natürlich noch in kleine stücke
schneiden aber sie werden automatisch
durch die hitze ein bisschen kleiner und
verlieren auch ganz viel wasser
[Musik]
so am besten immer umrühren damit euch
am topfboden auch nichts anbrennen
keine zwei minuten sind um ich habe die
zeit angehalten jetzt mache ich den herd
aus und jetzt können wir die masse
einmal umfallen so ich habe mir hier was
kleines vorbereitet das ist einmal einen
tortenring und einen tortenheber ihr
könnt falls er das alles nicht da habt
auch einfach nur die schüssel nehmen es
auch in ordnung wichtig ist nur dass
jetzt die tortenplatte 3 cm kleiner
eingestellt ist als unser boden mein
boden habt in 26 cm durchmesser und
deswegen habe ich den ring auf 23 cm
eingestellt und jetzt fühle ich die
heiße masse direkt vom herd hier ein
wichtig ist außerdem dass ihr hier
frischhaltefolie drunter liegt damit es
später auch noch rausholen können
[Musik]
so jetzt verteilen wir das ein bisschen
ich persönlich mag die erdbeer stückchen
verdi nicht mag kann das ganze natürlich
pürieren
aber dann habt ihr noch mal so schön bis
3 und jetzt gebe ich um darauf nochmal
frischhaltefolie und dann muss das ganze
eingefroren werden das dauert so ein
paar stunden das könnte auch am vorabend
zu bereiten
und weil ich weiß dass viele halt kein
platz im gefrierschrank haben könnt ihr
auch das so einmal nehmen und in den
kühlschrank geben für eine stunde
ungefähr
dann friert es ein bisschen an und dann
gibt das im nachhinein in eurer
gefrierfach dann könnte das nämlich auch
so schwenken und dann habt ihr da
bestimmt auch platz drin
als nächstes bereiten wir eine leckere
yogurette ghanas zu die besteht jetzt
nicht nur aus operette und sahne sondern
auch aus einem teil aus vollmilch
kuvertüre wer das nicht ganz so süß mag
der kann auch gerne tat bitter kuvertüre
nehmen wir benötigen folglich kuvertüre
die habe ich schon klein gehackt und in
eine große schüssel gegeben
außerdem yogurette die habe ich auch
klein geschnitten und ein wenig
schlagsahne als allererstes gebe ich die
yogurette stückchen jetzt zu meiner
kuvertüre so dass es schon mal
vorbereitet und dann kochen wir die
sahne in unserem kochtopf einmal auf
die milch kocht schon auf und jetzt
nämlich so schwer vom herd und dies die
einmal über die schokolade
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich einen deckel darüber oder
in meinem fall ist einen teller und dass
das fünf minuten stehen damit das
erstmal so in der hitze schmelzen kann
und anschließend dröhnen wir das einmal
oben
sonst nämlich einmal den teller hier
oben weg und es hat sich das schon so
ein bisschen aufgelöst ist müssen wir
das aber unter rühren komplett auflösen
lassen
[Musik]
jetzt hat sich alles miteinander
verbunden und das wird gleich noch
richtig schön fest aber ich sag euch ich
könnte mich auch so schon reinlegen
die garage ist jetzt fast fertig muss
aber noch vollständig auskühlen bevor
wir weitermachen können
ihr könnt das ganze beschleunigen indem
ihr das im kühlschrank gibt und immer
mal wieder um rührt aber wir haben noch
was zu tun denn in der zwischenzeit
machen wir dich zwischen gräben für die
sahne creme benötigen wir kalte
schlagsahne außerdem doppel ram
frischkäse sahne stand mittel etwas
puderzucker und etwas vanille extrakt
und das ist wieder mal eine super
einfache und schnelle creme einfach alle
zutaten in die schüssel und verrühren
ich benutze jetzt mein handrührgerät ihr
könnt natürlich auch die küchenmaschine
verwenden ist ganz euch überlassen
jetzt gebe ich hier noch puderzucker
reihen ihr könnt das auch so lassen ihr
müsst da nicht unbedingt die süße mit
rein geben dann werden wir auch vanille
extrakt und das süß schon zusätzlich
[Musik]
die zutaten in der schüssel verrühren
jetzt ganz kurz mit dem handmixer
so die zutaten sind jetzt gruppen
miteinander verrührt ist das grabmal so
30 sekunden gedauert und jetzt gebe ich
erst dass anstand mittel mit hinzu und
schlag das komplett steif auf höchster
stufe
[Musik]
so das war's schon so schnell gegen
diese cremen und wichtig ist halt dass
er die zutaten direkt aus dem
kühlschrank nimmt und die nicht erst auf
zimmertemperatur stehen
ich gebe die schüsse jetzt zurück in den
kühlschrank bis zu weitere verarbeitung
damit sie auch schön gekühlt bleibt so
wir haben uns jetzt alles vorbereitet
und können anfang in kuchen
zusammenzusetzen wichtig ist dass hier
noch einmal mein bizkit boden backt dann
habe ich schon vorbereitet und einmal
durch drei geteilt ich mache das immer
so damit das auch richtig schön aussieht
dass ich die oberseite vom bizkit boden
jetzt einmal umdrehen und als boden
nehmen und dann mache ich immer so
weiter und der boden ist dann quasi am
entdecken und dann habt ihr einen
richtig schönen geraden abschluss ich
gebe es zuallererst etwas von meiner
sahne creme auf den boden
[Musik]
allerdings nur ganz wenig gerade so als
würdet ihr euch ein butterbrot schmieren
und dann geben wird darüber unsere
frucht einlage die frucht einlage habe
ich jetzt ausnahmsweise mal nicht in den
tiefkühler gelegt weil das doch ein sehr
weit verbreitetes problem ist dass die
menschen einfach kein platz im
tiefkühler haben bei mir ist es auch
nicht anders
und deswegen war die jetzt nur im
kühlschrank im tiefkühler geht's
natürlich fester ihr könnte ganz einfach
drauf legen wie so eine platte und dann
wird die mit der zeit weich so ist es
jetzt wenn es auf dem kühlschrank kommt
und dann könnt ihr ganz einfach die
folie an der oberfläche entfernt einmal
umdrehen und darüber legen dann nimmt
sie die folie ab und ihr seht dass es
eigentlich auch gar kein problem
und jetzt geben wir darüber noch mal ein
ganz kleines bisschen von unserer sahne
creme
[Musik]
so jetzt geben wir den mittleren boden
darüber und dann kommt die komplette
restliche sahne creme auf den boden
[Musik]
und yogurette torte wäre ich kann dir
gerettet orte wenn wir nicht noch ein
paar yogurette smit rhein geben
[Musik]
jetzt geben wir die einfach über diese
schicht und dann haben wir noch mal
richtig leckeren yogurette geschmack in
der torte
[Musik]
jetzt geben wir unseren tortenboden als
deckel darüber dann drehen mit den um
und dann haben wir so einen richtig
schönen geraden abschluss und wenn ihr
nicht gerade einen kameramann habt der
hier reinen tisch mit seinem finger dann
habt ihr wirklich alles schön gerade
jetzt geben wir die yogurette kanalstadt
drüber und schaut mal die ist richtig
schön streich fest und so ist ja auch
genau richtig aber diese konsistenz
kriegt ihr nur wenn ihr sie auch
wirklich im kühlschrank lagert falls ihr
euch doch zu fest wird dann gibt er sie
über einem wasserbad dass das ganze noch
mal in ruhe im kühlschrank auskühlen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die torte schön
eingestrichen
und jetzt wird nur noch dekoriert da
könnt ihr natürlich selber entscheiden
aber weil sie gerade saison haben
nämlich auf jeden fall erdbeeren mit
rein
[Musik]
so und jetzt geben wir die erdbeer nur
noch drauf und ich lasse jetzt das grün
einfach mal dran weil es ist einfach
richtig schön finde
[Musik]
so die yogurette torte ist fertig die
gefällt mir richtig gut ich weiß ja
schon wenig schmeckt senden ich habe ja
mal bei meiner besten freunde zum
geburtstag mitgebracht letzte woche und
deshalb weil sich dass die richtig
richtig lecker schmeckt falls ihr das
ganze jetzt nach machen möchte dann habe
ich euch die genauen mengenangaben hier
unten in der infobox verlinkt also macht
euch ein screenshot ab zum supermarkt
und dann könnt ihr die leckere yogurette
torte nach backen
ich danke euch das einschalten und sagte
zum nächsten mal auf dieses kitchen
[Musik]